all right well thank you for joining me
good afternoon
hope you enjoyed lunch I'm gonna talk
about functional programming today in
JavaScript so we're going to utilize new
es6 syntax use that to explore some
functional concepts some of the basic
things about functional programming and
see how we can capitalize on some of the
new syntax and features to actually
write cleaner functional code so my name
is jeremy Fairbank a the blog blog at
Derby Fairbank calm and if you want to
follow me on twitter lil Pocoyo and je
ferme a on github just very briefly
about me I work for a company called cgn
or a completely remote team focused on
design and front-end development and in
addition to be an agency we have our own
product called simply build which is a
website builder and editor along with
domain management and hosting so primary
reason we're here today is because of
libraries like these and this sort of
Renaissance that's been happening at the
JavaScript world over the past few years
and it's functional programming has been
showing up more and more and I think
it's very important to understand why
these libraries problem my function
becomes what your programming has
becoming so important we have react and
redux and some reactive things like rxjs
faking Janus and lots of other libraries
so today we want to explore this what is
functional programming what does that
actually look like where's cortman
screaming and what would that feel like
compared to procedural style programming
object-oriented programming so the
bigger question though is life in tional
program why would it be important why
would we want to utilize it incorporate
it in our tool belt as programmers and
so we're gonna explore both of those
things and see what it looks like why it
might be useful to us so I want to start
off just thinking about basic building
blocks we think about it this is
functional programming the word function
is in it and as you might think
functions are going
to be our building once there are the
atomic pieces that all of this hinges
upon we're gonna use just functions to
build up very complex higher-order
patterns to write very elegant and
hopefully more error-free code so to
start off what is a function really if
we go back to elementary school math or
middle school math we might have seen
something like this where our teacher
told us it's a unique mapping from the
domain to arrange we have two different
sets and that might have been a little
esoteric or confusing and then we might
have gotten something a little more like
this f of X equals x plus 2 and so that
kind of clicked it's like okay this is
just something that takes an input we do
some computation and we produce an
output we understand that if I pass in 2
I get 2 plus 2 equals 4 bypassing 3 3
plus 2 equals 5 and so forth but what we
begin to look back in that earlier
definition you see an important property
about these functions especially in math
our input those are our arguments that
is the domain we have a set of numbers
that can go in and then we have a
guarantee that each of those inputs is
going to map uniquely to some sort of
output so that's the return value from a
function that's our range of values so
we see how those two things tie together
and so there was this guy named Alonzo
Church
he kind of capitalized on this idea of
modeling computation in terms of these
pure functions and he was actually a
professor of Allen Tariq's
so while Alan Turing was developing
these modes of computation based on the
Turing machine Alonzo Church actually
approached it from a different angle
where we could express computation in
terms of just small units of expressions
called lambda expressions and so we
developed what is called the lambda
calculus and it's a turing-complete
language itself and so we're gonna build
upon those very basic mathematical ideas
of just representing computation from
small units expressions lambdas
functions to explore functional
programming in the world of JavaScript
so if I had to distill this
down into some principles sorta like
solid from the object-oriented world I
would say we have four principles at
least within the context of this
discussion and so the first thing I
would say about functional programming
is that its predictable and what that
means is we have pure functions we have
declarative style programming and that
gives us certain guarantees where we
have better determinism I have
guarantees that since I have a pure
function I know that if I pass this in I
will always get back to some exact
output every time and so this gives us
certain guarantees on predictability we
also have safety this comes a lot from a
mutable state in that I don't mutate
state I keep the immutable city and if I
need to change it then I'll just create
a new state and that's going to protect
me from slight typos and other errors
that could crop up from beautiful state
in addition to being safe state we also
want it to be transparent so we want our
state to be out in the open we want
functions to compute on this data out in
the open we don't want to stuff it
behind objects that we just send
messages to and so we'll explore that as
well and then finally the idea of
modularity and this goes back to the
idea of functions as building blocks
that we can take these small pieces and
we can start piecing them together in
different ways through things like
currying and partial application to
below much higher order patterns and so
it empowers us to deduplicate our code
and have very modular code through
functional programming
now before we really dive into it let's
go over some of the es6 syntax that
we're going to utilize today in our code
and just get a feel for how we're going
to utilize it so the first thing we have
our new variable bindings before we
always have the var statement to declare
our variables now we have let in Const
the difference from these with bar is
that they are block scopes so with var
you know no matter where you place it
it's gonna get wasted up to the top of a
function scope in this case with
constant let they're just going to be
inside block scopes and they're not
going to leak out of that and then the
slight difference between wet and Const
is let is kind of like the new bar and
that I can assign a value and I can
always reassign it to a different value
whereas const is a constant binding does
it mean the value itself is constant but
the binding is constant which just means
once I sign a value to it I cannot
assign a different value to it to it
later that would be a syntax error
of course we're talking about functional
program we've talked about lambdas which
are anonymous functions and so we're
gonna have arrow functions which are one
of the biggest things that came with es6
so with an arrow function we have again
parameters and parentheses but now we
separate the parameters and the function
body with an arrow and then we can still
have a normal looking function body we
have our braces we have a return
statement and so it's very similar to
function declarations and function
function expressions that we already
have before
we can also ask you a couple things such
as the parentheses and the braces and in
this case with this identity function if
I leave out the braces that means that
this function has a single expression as
its body and it's implicitly returned so
I don't have to explicitly put return x
here and notice also if I have a single
argument I can also leave out the
parenthesis and just have X without
parenthesis and so this is just a simple
identity function to highlight how we
can write very succeed simple looking
arrow functions
another thing we can add to our
functions is utilizing the rest spread
operator and it's the three dots
ellipsis operator and when we use it in
parameters it allows us to represent
that this function takes a variable
number of arguments in this case I have
an array function it takes a variable
number of elements and then I'm just
going to rear atern those elements
because they're going to get placed
inside of an array when I use this rest
operator so I call the Ray on one two
three and I get back a literal array
with one two and three in it
I can also use this as a spread operator
so in addition to gathering up variable
number of arguments I can also pass
variable number of arguments into
function so I can just gather up my
arguments here pass them back into
console dot log so this is a nice
cleaner way of doing the old method of
calling the functions apply method where
you could pass variable number for
arguments in that way and that's
something from earlier versions of
JavaScript so here I can just pass in
variable number hello scenic city summit
and all those get passed in the console
log
another thing that will utilize some is
destructuring
and if you are Python person a ruby
person and I'm sure there are other
languages that utilize this it's this
idea that I could take a complex data
structure like a list and array a tupple
and I can pull out multiple values from
it and put them in different variables
so in this case I have an array of
languages JavaScript Ruby Haskell and I
can pull out individual elements by
signing it to this Const with the Gracie
races Jas and then using that rest
operator again with a rest variable name
and so what that basically does is it's
saying take the first item which is
JavaScript assign it to the Jas variable
in your binding and then I use the rest
operator and that's saying take whatever
else is left in the array and just stuff
it in this rest variable and so that
gives me Jas is JavaScript rest at the
first index is Ruby rest at the second
index is Haskell
I can also use this in my function
parameters so I can have a head function
and it takes an array and its purpose is
just to return the first element in the
array well I could just utilize these
structuring here and say pull out the
first item go ahead and sign it to the
binding X and then just return that X
and so we'll see more examples of this
later it's just sort of introducing you
to what kind of es6 syntax we're going
to utilize in our functional code
the other thing which is widely
available on a lot of other languages is
default parameter values normally in
JavaScript we would have to just check
if the value has or if the parameter has
about you because essentially all
arguments can be optional in JavaScript
functions and then we would have to
assign later on with this we can
declaratively say okay if there's
nothing passed in at this argument
position then go ahead and pre fill it
with this default value so Greek here
has a name argument and a greeting
argument which we say has a default
value of hi so if I call greet with
scenic city summit and hello then I'll
get back hello scenic city summit
because I've passed in both arguments
but if I say greet with just Chattanooga
I have not supplied value for reading so
it'll use the default value which is
high and we'll just print out high
chatting again
one of the other things and this isn't
necessarily a syntactical thing but it's
just a new function available in es6 and
you've probably seen something similar
to this from lodash or underscore called
a sign and it's on the object object in
JavaScript and so what it basically
allows us to do is just to merge
multiple objects together whatever
argument is at the first position will
be mutated so typically we'll just pass
in an empty object here and then what
that allows us to do is pass in a
variable number of other objects and
just merge them all together and then
give us back a final object that has all
the keys and values from the other
objects and whatever objects come last
in that chain will override other values
if they happen to have the same key and
we'll use this later an example as well
and then finally we have es6 classes we
in fact won't use these in the
functional code but we'll use it to
contrast this some object-oriented code
but I still want to make sure you're
familiar with this es6 class syntax so
it's basically just syntactical sugar
for constructor functions from
JavaScript there's nothing really
special about them so this class point I
can define a constructor method and it
takes some arguments X Y and a science
instance variables that's the same as
just a constructor function called point
and then that move by method on the Left
that's the same as if I had just
assigned a move by function to the
points prototype and so we'll see this
later and contrast it with some
functional approaches so that covers
some of the es6 syntax that we're going
to see and we'll see them plenty more
coming up in our examples as we look at
the functional code so now returning
back to our principles we want to first
talk about predictability and we said in
this predictability we have pure
functions so we want to see what does
that mean what does it mean to be a pure
function and what's important about that
so a very simple example is this add
function takes x and y returns x plus y
this is a pure function because all it
does is it depends on its arguments and
produces a value based on those
arguments it does not have what we call
side effects it does not depend on
global State it does not mutate global
State it doesn't even print to standard
out which we also
considered to be a side effect and what
that gives us as a pure functions is
this guarantee that every time I call
add with two and three I always get back
five and that's another property that we
like to call referential transparency
and that's just a fancy way of saying
that I know every time I call this I get
back five so in fact I could replace
calls to this particular invocation with
just the number five and it would not
change the meaning of my program overall
and so it's guaranteed that's wise
what's so important pure functions if
they don't have side effects we know
they produce the same thing every time
then we have better better assurance
that our program is correct
so what then is impure well we have this
contrived example here of some functions
of an API that depends on this global
variable called name we're using a let
binding so it can be mutated it can be
changed the value of it so each of these
functions are impure get name is impure
because it depends upon that global
state if that global state changed which
it can because of the set name function
then we no longer have a guarantee that
get name will always produce the same
values therefore it's an impure function
similarly like I said set name is impure
because it mutates and changes that
global state and then that bottom
function print upper name well it's
impure for a couple of reasons it
depends upon the global state again
we're printing out the name uppercase
but it's also printing to the console
which technically you would say it makes
it impure because we could think of
standard out it's just some more global
state that we are affecting in our
function so why does it really matter I
mean is this that terrible to write
impure functions like this I would say
it can be a little harder to test it and
that's what I think is so crucial about
pure functions so if I wanted to test
this particular API and test the print
upper named function well first I need
to make sure that I mock console.log so
I can track calls to it and then I gotta
make sure I restore it after a test so
then I can print up a name I can check
the console log was called with
uppercase Jeremy but notice that the
functions I call my API are separate
from the assertions I need to make so I
have do more due diligence on my part as
a programmer to remember I mutating some
states and I need to check that this
particular function was called with this
particular argument and so it's putting
more burden on us and it's making it
slightly harder to test now this is an
easy easier example but you can imagine
more complex examples with asynchronous
things how mocking can get pretty
frustrating and annoying
so one thing I like to say about this is
that we have a lot of hidden state and
that's uncertain state because we have
to say set name print upper name we're
doing all these mew mew mutating
functions we have to remember that some
state is changing behind the scenes and
that can make it harder to test so what
would be the remedy if we wrote it in a
pure fashion testing suddenly becomes a
lot easier so now I just write it up her
name function it takes a name and it
returns name dot to uppercase
that's easy to test it's a pure function
I know that if I pass in Jeremy I get
back Jeremy uppercase if I pass in jet I
get jet uppercase and so that's one of
the beautiful things about writing pure
functions and trying to do that as much
as possible in our programs it's a whole
lot easier to test we're just testing
inputs and outputs
so moving forward we talked about purity
we also talked about when we have this
predictable principle that we have
declarative programming and understand
declarative style program we need to
first look at what is called imperative
and this is something we're probably
already doing and it's this idea we we
tell the computer how to achieve a
particular result what does that look
like so if I have this double numbers
function takes an array of numbers and
then it's going to produce a new array
of numbers where every number has been
doubled
pretty simple so we'll create an array
to hold all these values we'll do a for
loop where we're incrementing some index
variable and push those into the new
array when we double them and then we
return it but we say this is an
imperative style and if if not for the
function names it might take us a second
to read through the source code I know
oh this function doubles numbers and you
can see we're just giving a set of
instructions to the computer it's not
declaring what we're really doing here
so what does it clear it it then well
declare it it is instead of saying how
to do it we're saying what we need that
declare what our result we want and this
is something you're probably already
doing to whether you realize it or not
if you do a lot of database queries
sequel that's a declarative language you
don't tell the database engine how to
get the data set you just tell it what
data set you want or if you're a
front-end developer HTML that's the
clarity of language you don't tell the
browser how to paint it you tell it what
to paint what you would like it to look
like so how do we apply that then to
JavaScript and functional programming
well now we can like three lines we can
do the double numbers with the native
map method on the numbers array so we
take the numbers we call numbers that
map we pass in an arrow function and we
can look at this pretty quickly even
without a function a and say oh in maps
to end times two and we're mapping that
for every item in the array that's a
very declarative thing we don't know how
Maps implemented internally by v8 or
SpiderMonkey but we know this is what we
desire as our result and just to kind of
tie this back to what we discussed with
the mathematical roots of this we can
see that we're mapping from a certain
domain a subset of one two three
to arrange subsets of two four six so
this is a very declarative style in it
again it makes our our programs more
predictable because we know they're pure
we know that they are written in a
declarative fashion we can reason about
them better so now moving on let's go to
state we talked about the principle of
safety and that was immutable state and
the idea is we don't want a mutator
state we don't want to change properties
on objects we don't want to change items
in an array instead we would prefer just
to create a new state if we need to
change it don't mutate what we have
because that could lead to subtle bugs
and issues in our programs
look here's an example very contrived
example let's say I have an array of
hobbies programming reading music and
then let's say I want to grab the first
two out of that I want to log them out I
gives me programming and reading that's
fine and then later on I want to print
out again what was in the hobbies rate
originally now I'm getting back just
music so what was the problem here well
in this case I just had a slight typo
but I had a mutable state
I used the splice method accidentally
instead of the slice method in
JavaScript which normally just gives you
a copy new array with the VAT the
indices that you specify splice is
similar but it will mutate it will
change the original array and just cut
out those values from the original array
so this is an instance very contrived of
where subtle issues can happen in our
programs and where mutability can trip
us up and we don't realize it so there's
a couple things we can do to alleviate
this back in es5 object up freeze was
introduced which is a function that
allows us to as the name suggests freeze
an object or an array prevent it from
being mutated and so that's a nice
approach to utilize and we'll see that
in a second another approach that I
highly recommend is immutable j/s which
is a library from Facebook and it has a
lot of immutable data structures that
you can utilize
don't we wanted to apply just the object
dot freeze all we need to do is call
object uh freeze on array and now when
we mess up and we miss type slice we put
splice it's going to throw a type error
so at the very least we're going to get
an error to say hey you may not meant to
do this because you have a mutable state
and you don't want to mutate it and so
hopefully we can catch this bug earlier
because of that and so immutability can
give us this these sort of safety
guarantees to a certain extent and help
us out a lot in our programs
so another thing as we talk about safety
we talked about also transparency we
want our state to be transparent we want
it to be out in the open and what that
means is if we think of object-oriented
styles of programming where we we stuff
our state behind an object we send it
messages we mutate that state but as we
saw earlier with some of our testing
code samples it can get harder for us to
reason about what's happening in our
program we have to remember how these
things mutate our internal state so
returning back to that point class this
is class example we set a point at the
origin and then we want to move it by
certain DX and dy but it's all mutating
something underneath and that can be
harder to reason about like I mentioned
and not to mention when we deal with
mutable state we might run into certain
bugs that we didn't anticipate in our
programs so how do we approach this name
of functional programming
well that is to just expose our state
don't mutate it keep it out in the open
and have explicit flow of data so now
instead of using a class let's just have
a create point function it takes the X
into y but let's just represent it our
coordinates as an array of two items
kind of like a double and we'll also
freeze it to keep it immutable to make
sure we don't accidentally youtaite it
and now when we want to move the point
we won't change the values in that array
will actually produce a new array so
move point by notice we're going to use
that destructuring syntax that I used
earlier so when I pass in the point I'll
go ahead and D stretch the array back
out to the x and y coordinates I'll also
take the DX and dy and then I can add
those create a new array freeze it again
and now when I create the point if I
want to move it well I just need to go
ahead and create a new point you keep
that state we're out in the open and
have this explicit flow of data where
instead of mutating stuff underneath we
just have functions that operate on data
and produce new data and so this can
give us other guarantees on how our data
is flowing through our programs and
we're not hiding as much behind objects
so looking at immutability the safety
guarantees transparency there are
definitely pros and cons so we we've
mentioned some of these pros we have
safety we saw with the hobbies example
where we can maybe catch bugs earlier
because we're using a mutable state if
you have user heard of Redux one huge
benefit of it is that it forces you to
always produce new state in your
applications and so if you use Redux dev
tools or something like that you
basically get free undo redo logs for
free and that's really nice because
since it doesn't let you mutate your
state you just create new state you can
hold on to that old state and that makes
it easier to debug your programs if you
need to go back in time essentially we
saw we have an explicit flow of data too
so we can reason about what's going on
in our programs a little easier and then
I have a couple points there which
aren't caveated
we say less memory uses you will see
what that means in this next slide but
we also say we have some concurrent
concurrency safety now javascript single
threaded but we can still run into race
conditions if we have potential multiple
asynchronous
actions out on the out on the wire and
maybe they're gonna affect some shared
state if they don't change the state in
a certain order that we expect then we
can still run into race conditions but
if our states immutable and we don't
want to mutate it then we don't have to
worry about this so we have concurrency
safety already
now some of the cons which I'll omit
there is a little more verbosity we're
bringing our state out in the open we're
not hiding it behind objects we don't
have these always nice clean interfaces
where we just call some method and we
know the state that's hidden gets
changed if we're creating new objects
then that also means there's potential
for more garbage collection and actually
there's potential for more memory usage
which is that odds from what I said
earlier these are caveat it as well
especially if you use a library like the
beautiful Jas if you use something like
you double J s it's smart enough to when
you create new objects to know how to
sometimes share the underlying data
between two objects because it's
immutable you can share that data you
don't have to worry about something
mutating it and breaking it and we won't
have time in this talk to really dive
into a mutable j/s but if you're curious
about functional programming I highly
recommend checking it out utilizing it
so now we've talked about state and
we've talked about things like purity
and declarative style programming so now
that we have some of that foundation
underway let's start looking just at
functions and how we can see important
properties of functions in JavaScript
and especially in functional languages
that empower us to do some really cool
modular style programming and just
treating these as small atomic pieces so
this first thing we'll talk about it's
pretty much a given whether we realize
it or not is that this idea of
first-class functions JavaScript has
functions as first-class citizens so
what does that mean when I do this
Kant's multiply equals some anonymous
function the fact that I can assign a
function to a variable is actually a
very powerful concept whether we realize
it or not this means it's a first-class
citizen in our language no different
than a boolean a string a number because
I can assign those two variables I can
pass them as arguments
I can take a function declaration I can
alias it to some other variable binding
and like I mentioned we can pass in
functions as arguments and we've
probably been doing this for a long time
especially if we're JavaScript
programmers but it's it's nice sometimes
to sit back and think about wow this is
actually very powerful and a very useful
thing many languages years ago didn't
have something like this and it's very
empowering to have it within our
repertoire
so we can build upon that especially in
JavaScript and utilize what's called
closures and you've probably heard of
this but it allows us to encapsulate
certain state and that's what we're
gonna need when we want to start looking
at in a few minutes partial application
currying and composing functions which
allow us to do this building up to
higher-order patterns from very small
small pieces so what is a closure if I
take my add function from before and now
I'm gonna separate out the arguments I'm
gonna create this create a door function
and notice all it does is it takes an X
argument and now it's going to return a
new function again I can return a
function because it's a first-class
citizen when you in fact would say that
this create a door function is a
higher-order function because it it
returns a function as a value so I
return this new function it takes a Y as
argument and then inside we finally do
our computation X plus y so we can kind
of delay our computation but we can use
this as a small building block to build
other functions without explicitly
writing them so I can create a function
that adds 3 to whatever's passed in just
by calling create adder with 3 I'm
essentially filling in X to be 3 and
notice inside that second function when
I when I invoke that at the bottom I'm
referring to that X that was passed in
earlier that's a closure I'm closing
over that X reference right there in
that later function it's able to
remember what that value is and utilize
it and that's a very critical concept
that we'll utilize as we keep building
on these foundational patterns
so what's the more practical example of
this for example to look at let's say we
have a request function and that's just
responsible for wrapping over the fetch
API which is essentially a nicer way of
doing xhr calls to you know our API
endpoints so I can call a couple API
endpoints but let's say I have these
custom headers I always need to send up
to my API well that could get slightly
repetitive so of course I could just
write a function that always passes
those headers up but we would like for
this to be more general purpose ideally
so what approach we could do and I will
caveat that technically this function is
impure but what we could do is we could
take that same concept we did with
create adder we could take options as an
argument and then we can return another
function it will take other options and
then we'll finally call the original
request function and we'll use object to
a subject on a sign to merge all those
in so all that is is a fancy way of
saying I want to go ahead and pre-fill
some defaults some shared options in
this case my custom header that I want
to use and that reduces that duplication
so that's one benefit of using closures
we can reduce some of the stupid Kayson
and then I can just invoke my different
api's with their URLs
so therefore we take the options and we
can refer to it inside that inner
function so these first class closures
they are going to be this foundation for
these higher-order patterns that we're
going to start diving into now and
looking at
so the first thing is partial
application and what partial application
is going to do is we can ask the quit
and see well you know I have this create
adder I have this create requester and I
can keep doing this pattern over and
over and over and it's going to get a
little tedious so what if we could have
some more general-purpose way to
essentially fill in those X or fill in
that options and that's one thing we can
do with partial application so we could
return the same add is just a function
that takes X and y returns X plus y and
then let's say we had this hypothetical
function called partial we can pass in
add to it again because these are
first-class citizens in our language and
then I can pass in 3 and what I'm saying
is take this function whatever its first
argument is let it be 3 pre fill it with
3 and that gives me back this add 3
function that when I invoke it all it
needs to do now is fill in its argument
with Y and then I can return the result
same thing with the request function we
could do the same thing if we had this
hypothetical partial function I could
call it on my request function and now
what I'll do is I'll have it take two
arguments a defaults and options and
then we'll just merge those with object
on sign but I can use partial to
pre-fill in those defaults whatever
shared options I need my custom headers
in this example
so how would we implement this partial
function that we keep talking about well
it's actually very simple to implement
with es6 and also if you are big Moe -
four underscore fan partial is also
available in those languages if you
don't want to implement it yourself but
we can take two different approaches to
it the first approach is we can actually
utilize something that's already
natively available in JavaScript if
you've heard of the bind method on
functions what it normally does is it
allows you to bind the this context in
JavaScript and if you've done JavaScript
for quite a while you have probably run
into issues with this so you can use
that to just say set the this special
variable to a certain context one not
very well known thing about buying
though is any number of extra arguments
you pass into it can actually be
partially applied arguments so it
essentially does what we just saw in
those previous slides with the
hypothetical partial function so what I
can do is I can just capitalize on this
we're not worried about this where we're
functional programmers we don't want to
use this so we'll just pass in null for
that first argument and then we'll use
the spread rest operator here to just
pull in all the variable number of
arguments that we want to partially
apply into this function and just
pre-fill their values
now if we wanted to handwrite it all
ourself it's not that much more complex
we just utilize the rest spread operator
a little more so again we take a
variable number of arguments after our
function we return another function that
takes in additional arguments again
variable number so we'll use the rest
operator and then finally we can invoke
the original function we can do that
it's a closure so we're referring to it
when we originally passed it in and then
we just make sure to pass in first all
those pre filled arguments the arms
variable and then pass in the other arms
that we just passed in and so that
allows us to accomplish our own partial
function in pure JavaScript
so now let's take that concept a little
further what would be really nice is if
actually we didn't even need to call
partial on some function it would be
nice if our functions just sort of had
this concept built into them already
where they could partially apply on
their own we don't have to manually do
that and that's what we call currying so
there's that subtle difference
so what that means is with currying what
I do here see as I call ad and I only
pass in three
and that's going to go ahead and
pre-fill X to be three so what this is
smart enough to know is that you haven't
given me all of the arguments yet so I'm
just going to go ahead and fill in what
you have given me until I have all of my
arguments satisfied and that's what
happens when I then evoke add three with
two and get back five I could apply the
same concept again to our request
function pre-fill any default shared
argument such as the headers and then
invoke it again with our API endpoints
so how do we accomplish currying with
javascript in es6 well little secret we
already did it earlier with the create
adder function only thing is I wrote it
differently what we're doing now is
we're just writing it in one line using
the arrow functions and just using that
single expression body at least for this
add function so notice here we have two
arrows now maybe a little confusing but
let's just take it from left to right so
first add takes the X so what we saw
earlier with create adder and it returns
a new function that takes a why we've
just be lighted the braces this time
when we put it all on one line so we
take the y and then we have another
arrow which maps them to X plus y so the
basic general rule of thumb you can
think of this is that instead of using
commas to separate our arguments we'll
just separate them with arrows and that
essentially gives us a rudimentary
curried function and then at the bottom
just so you kind of see what's happening
there's the old es side version of this
function where we just declare a
function add and then we'll see where we
return anonymous function that takes a Y
same thing with the request function
that we've been using in our examples
separate our arguments with the arrows
and that gives us this nice curried
function where we can just build in
partial application automatically so
it's really powerful wonderful concept
so this is all well a good nice
interesting topics but is it practical
is it useful how could we really use
this in real code
so let's actually piece this together
and see a not a not unrealistic example
how this might be useful how we could
take small building blocks to solve a
slightly harder problem so I have this
contrived example where we're going to
basically query a API for a shopping
cart and whatever items are in the cart
and what I do is I just want to take the
price of each item apply a discount and
apply the tax rate to it and we're just
going to use curried functions and
promises to accomplish this so the first
thing is we're going to write a map
function and what we're going to do is
make it a curried function its first
argument will be the function that we
want to eventually apply to an array of
items the second argument will be the
actual array and then we'll just
delegate to the original array dot map
implementation remember we saw that
earlier when we wanted to double numbers
we have to call it rate map you pass in
that function that map's in to n times 2
or we're just making this more general
purpose here where we can give it any
arbitrary function to use
we'll have a multiply function that's
just like our add function we're just
you in multiplication this time
we're gonna have this reflect function
and essentially what that does this is
actually a function in low - - that does
this the same thing but we're going to
take in the key stream as the first
argument second argument would be an
object and what we want to accomplish is
just basically pull out whatever value
exists at that particular key for that
object
and so now here's how we can start
utilizing these curried functions
instead of writing a discount function
instead of writing a tax function I'm
just going to use my multiplied function
because I can express the discount I can
express the tax rate in terms of
multiplication if I want to apply a 2%
discount then I'll just multiply by 0.98
so that'll decrease by the two percent
of the original price same thing with
the tax rate if I want a nine and a
quarter percent tax rate I'll just
multiply by one point zero nine two five
this is a curried function so all I've
done is I've filled in X it's still
waiting on that Y which will be the
price that we'll get eventually
already seen this we're using our
courage request function to filling our
custom headers
and then finally we'll make our API
request and then we're going to look at
that a little more closer to see how
we're utilizing everything up top there
to handle a lot of complex stuff down
there on the bottom
so what we're essentially doing here is
we make this request we're using
promises it's going to eventually
resolve we're going to get back this
response an array with three items the
prices are five ten and three dollars
and then we're going to use attach the
ven callbacks or the promise and we're
going to pass in functions to operate on
this data but look how essentially more
declarative this can be we can read this
and say okay when I get this response I
know I want to pluck out the price I
want to map in the discount and I want
to map in the tax rate so taking those a
step at a time
remember pluck price curried function
will give it a key gives us back a
function that expects an object so we
still have a function map expects a
function so we give map that particular
function that's going to pluck out the
price and then once the promise resolves
the map function is going to finally
supply the array and it's going to map
that plunk function over every item in
the array so there we can pull out five
ten and three
next it's going to send down that array
of prices to map discount again discount
we created by just invoking multiply
once with the discounted rate and then
maps going to apply that to every item
and similarly with our tax rate we'll
make sure that we can just apply it all
at once and so this gives us a very
definitely interesting way to do a lot
of this complex stuff but with very
small building blocks that we just use
creat functions to express this in a
very pure and declarative manner
now one final thing we can do with this
though is talk about composing closures
composing functions together building
upon creed functions and if you've heard
of this
you may remember again back to math when
you compose functions say you had f of X
and a DX and you compose them you
produce some sort of F of G of X or GM f
of X but the basic idea is especially if
maybe you've done some UNIX shell
programming or something this idea of
piping one thing to the other where you
have something that takes input it
produces an output its output becomes
the input to something else so you're
just chaining these together and you're
passing data down the pipeline and
that's essentially what composing
functions is
so if I had something like this
processed word and we're going to use
some we won't show the implementation of
these functions but we have - a traverse
to uppercase they're fairly
self-explanatory reverse will reverse
the string - a it's going to put a
hyphen in the middle as best as possible
but I want to say apply all these
functions at once so what I could do is
I could compose them together take all
the functions chain them together -
where it becomes one new function that
applies all these one at a time and by
convention
normally with compose we would go from
right to left
now we'll mention again compose this is
not something built into JavaScript so
this is another hypothetical function
but it's available in low - and
underscore and there's actually a
different version called flow which is
basically doesn't left to right instead
and this can be implemented as well I
don't have time to show the
implementation of this but the slides
online will have a basic example of how
you could write it yourself if you're
interested but see what I can do here is
I can chain them together and then I can
get map over these this array of words
and apply each function one at a time to
each item I don't have to call it on my
own it just chain together for one
function and just to show you what that
kind of looks like explicitly is if I
wrote it explicitly down there on the
bottom it's essentially as if I'd call
to uppercase with word and then just let
that get passed into reverse and
whatever that produces get passed into
hyphenate but we've just made this a
general-purpose approach or we can
compose them together and do it any more
declarative fashion
so how is this you so how could we
utilize it well I should let's go back
to our example we just saw earlier with
the shopping cart notice here what we
had done get mapped over the array three
times so sorry about that so we had
basically we'd iterated three times and
in this case it's not a big deal we had
three items in our way but if we have
something that's more performant
intensive maybe we're operating a lot of
data we may not want to iterate three
times transforming all these items in
the array so what we could actually do
is just add composition to the mix here
so now we can make this a single
iteration remember map just needs a
function so I could produce a new
function where I take plucking the price
out applying the discount applying the
tax rate all compose together that gives
me one function that does it all
together and then give that to map and
that ensures that we can apply all these
functions in one iteration instead of
three iterations so this can be very
useful to just apply multiple things at
once to array of items for example
so we've done a lot with functions we've
talked a lot about state and mobility
one thing we haven't quite covered
especially when we think back to
imperative style programming is how to
deal with the loop issue sometimes we
have problems that we have to use a loop
to solve it and we've already said that
loops those are imperative it we use
mutable state and it's not something we
necessarily desire to do in functional
programming so how do we tackle this
particular issue in functional
programming well this is where we would
incorporate recursion and you maybe use
recursion before especially if you're
doing a lot of graph traversal type
problems and whatnot but it's a very
powerful and declarative way to solve
these type of loop issues in functional
programming and we essentially just want
to solve a problem in terms of itself so
a classic example of this if we go back
to that is the factorial remember with
factorial we have a number and
exclamation point in this case for
exclamation-point factorial 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 that gives us 24 and in
general we would say that we have n
factorial would be n times n minus 1
times n minus 2 and so on until we get
down to 1 again so if we wanted to solve
this in JavaScript we might take the
imperative approach we said okay well
this looks like I need a loop so we
could start an initial result value of 1
we do a while loop where we multiply by
the result by whatever in is passed into
the vectorial and we just decrement it
we keep looping until we reach the end
of the loop and that that works fine but
we don't want to do this in functional
programming we want a slightly more
declarative approach
so instead we could do this in a
recursive manner where you can write
actually fewer lines of code and we can
actually express the problem closer to
its original mathematical definition
even so notice here factorial ends up
calling itself and notice it actually
models that general representation of
factorial that I mentioned earlier in
times n minus 1 times n minus 2 and etc
except here notice we have n times
factorial of n minus 1 so it's
essentially going to keep calling this
recursive function over and over doing
the N minus 1 n minus 2 and etc but
eventually we need to stop and we're
going to get an infinite loop and that's
where we have what's called a base case
and recursive functions in this
particular instance we know we're going
to stop at 1 so we're going to check
whenever n is less than 2 go ahead and
return 1 and that although of the
answers start bubbling back up and give
us the final answer to the original call
so if we did this as factorial 4
remember this is going to make a
recursive call n times factorial of n
minus 1 so that's 4 times factorial 3
and that will in turn call factorial of
2 factorial 1 and now we've reached that
base case remember n is less than 2 so
now we can return the 1 and they will
just start bubbling up the answer 2
times 1 3 times 2 and then 4 times 6 and
that's how we can solve it in a very
declarative cursive manner and this is a
general approach you can apply to a lot
of problems and there's just a couple
steps if you have a math background you
did maybe a lot of inductive proofs back
in the day it's very similar that you
need to find what's called a recurrence
kind of ties in with that word cursive
what patterns you need to repeat this is
also very important in dynamic
programming if you've done a lot of that
in this case n times n minus 1 times n
minus 2 etc and then we need a base case
we just need to know where does this
stop at so we don't have an infinite
loop
so what's the performance story on all
this though
what if I wanted to call a factorial
100,000 what am I going to get back
actually get back nothing I'm gonna have
a range error maximum call stack size
exceeded so what is that actually all a
balance does that mean that we can't do
recursive functions that this isn't
gonna work
not necessarily but what what does it
actually mean so what what's going on
here let's go back and trace through
these calls and let's put a call stack
next to this so we call factorial 4
imagine the call stack we add in stack
frame for this particular call we know
it makes a recursive call to factorial 3
so let's have a stack frame for that
same thing with factorial 2 factorial 1
but notice what's happening here our
stack keeps growing and growing and
growing thankfully we've reached the
base case here so we can start popping
off the stack frames and getting back
answers
but what happens when we do factorial
100000 so the stack grew order of ov in
so a hundred thousand calls means a
hundred thousand stack frames and then
depending on what environment year
you're in when I did some of these
calculations I was an older version of
no but at that time a stack frame was
usually around 48 bytes the max your
call stack could grow would be around a
megabyte little less than that so a
hundred thousand times 48 converting
that into megabytes we attempt to use
4.5 eight megabytes and we were limited
to less than a megabyte so that's why we
got this particular error so does that
mean we can't solve this particular
issue with recursion not necessarily so
another thing in the s6 is this thing
called tail call optimization and it's a
really powerful concept in functional
programming where we could treat the
problem this recursive problem if there
was some way instead of growing the
stack we could just replace stack frames
because we're basically solving a
problem in terms of itself and so the
critical key point to this is we need to
make sure that the recursive call
happens in what's called the tail call
position which essentially means it
needs to be the very last statement in
our return statement the very thing
that's very less thing that's evaluated
in our return statement so our original
example we couldn't you can optimize
this for tail calls and you know I'm
saying well there's factorial it's in
the return call it should be fine right
if we follow the order valuation here we
have n minus 1 then we have factorial of
n minus 1 but the last thing is we still
need to perform this multiplication step
so we are forcing the program for every
recursive call it has to wait on the
recursive call to come back before it
can finally produce an answer therefore
we have no choice but to keep growing
the stack
but we can change how we define the
function and make it optimizable and
what we're going to essentially do is
actually just introduce another argument
and this is usually the the typical
pattern you use when you need to make
tail call optimized functions is you
want something that's called an
accumulator and so we're going to call
it a kyun for short we're going to use
the default value for the parameter set
it to 1 and so typically you want it to
start off with whatever your base case
return value was we knew that was 1
so when in is less than two instead of
returning one will return whatever
accumulated this but the critical thing
here is now we've moved that
multiplication to inside the recursive
call so we still have into minus one but
now we're doing in times Q and so as the
name suggests in the accumulator it's
going to start accumulating the final
result through each recursive call so
the order evaluation here now in minus
1/n times a q and then finally now the
factorial is the final statement in this
return statement and now we can optimize
this so what that means is if I know
that I can call a factorial with a
certain number and it basically is no
different than calling factorial with
different arguments there in the bottom
then I could theoretically just would
play stack frames and we'll see that so
if we do it we now to get back about you
you get back infinity but that's just
because of number overflow issues in
JavaScript but that means we can solve
these problems to a certain extent still
with recursive functions so I mentioned
what does this look like now with the
call stack
well can we do in fact toilet for we
have an implicit one there remember
we're just using the default values
let's my commented it out so we've had
this stack frame with factorial a four
and one
it's going to make a recursive call to
factorial 3 & 4 so actually we could say
factorial of 4 & 1 is no different than
calling factorial of 3 & 4 therefore I
can just replace the stack frame with
factorial 3 & 4
well that's no different than calling
factorial 2 and 12 so just replace that
and that's no different than calling
factorial 1 and 24 and notice there on
the right we've been accumulating our
answer remember 24 was the final answer
here so we've just been accumulating it
in that second argument position and
then we've reached the base case so
we'll just return that that's how we can
solve these type of recursive problems
still in an optimized way thanks to this
new feature in es6 but I believe it's
actually natively available now in the
latest version of Safari
although Babel is able to basically do
this for you under the hood if you want
to transpile it as well
so wrapping up we've covered a lot of
topics here I just want to recap and
kind of see what we've discussed and why
it was important we talked about some
principles predictability we have pure
functions we have declarative style
programming that allowed us to have
better guarantees better deterministic
outlooks on how our functions are going
to operate and that helps us have better
trust in our programs that we're not
necessarily always been a run into
subtle issues and bugs especially for
mutable state we also talked about this
safety we want to use immutable state
create new state we also want our state
to be transparent out in the open we
don't want to just hide it all behind
objects that we send messages to now we
talked about this modular concept that
we can take tiny tiny pieces through
creating through composition and we can
build up more and more complex patterns
and more and more complex functions just
out of that and solve actually decent
problems so I just want to leave you
with some final resources these slides
will be on available online as well
this is Professor frisbees mostly
adequate guide to functional programming
it's becoming definite required reading
for someone that wants to do functional
programming in JavaScript brian lonsdorf
is very very intelligent smart K and I
highly recommend checking this book out
he covers a lot more than I do and
probably more eloquently than I ever
could so definitely check this book out
we've been talking a lot about Mia's sex
- and if you want to utilize that
especially for older browsers I highly
recommend checking out babble so you can
transpile code into equivalent es5 code
that can run in older browsers if you
want to try out a different language
that actually trans files to JavaScript
I highly recommend these languages
element pure script our Haskell inspired
languages and very very powerful
language especially Elms becoming much
and much more popular
there's also Clojure script which is
basically an implementation of closure
for the browser if you've not heard of
closure it's basically a lisp that runs
on the JVM
some libraries that we've already
mentioned before lodash rammed great
functional libraries it's also rxjs and
bacon genius if you want to check out
reactive functional programming and then
of course we already mentioned immutable
Jas that allows you to have immutable
data structures
and then for the MV star crowd of course
I'm going to highly recommend react and
redux which definitely espousal out a
functional concept so if you want to
potentially take this somewhere else I
would highly recommend them that at the
very least utilizing Redux to
potentially handle your application
state even if you're using something
like angular and with all of that thank
you all so very much for joining me and
there's links for codes and slides
[Applause]